good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast I have a [ __ ] headache
good morning Millennials I fell asleep
with the headache and I guess in my
sleep it travelled uptown and we surely
tail-head know it's like right here oh
my god so it's not a migraine it's like
a full headache like and I woke up with
it I just I really haven't been getting
any sleep in like the past six months
and I need to sleep I had one day to
sleep in on Sunday and it was up till
5:00 in the morning watching Desperate
Housewives and woke up at 10:00 so like
what yeah I just I can't miss I just I
need to sleep I need a little bit stop
sleeping I wake up everyday from the
doorbell because it's the O's Walker
that's a nice way to wake up it is but
it's also like [ __ ] off you know what I
could for sure but I'm taking the dog
don't know what I'm just realizing now
like so I've been getting like really
bad migraines or headaches before I go
to sleep but we're like and I feel like
it's associated with like stress and now
I'm thinking like I feel like my stomach
pits have now become head pits like I
haven't gotten a stomach ache pit in a
while but now I have headache but
headaches like there are a million and
one things that can be related to
getting migraines where it's like a
belly ache like you know it's like
because you're nervous in that you could
poop for sure but I'm just saying they
could think it's made its way up I've
been trying to figure out for years for
the record I would prefer a stomach
headache a stomach pit if many of the
body gods are listening well I I've been
trying to figure out what my like
trigger is for migraines for years I'm
pretty sure it's lack of sleep and like
days I know and I'm getting a migraine
when it's a gray outside or I like
haven't had a chance to sit you know
yeah well that's gonna be today today is
a busiest day really oh but can I go
talk boat X we're getting our eyebrows
waxed we're getting our your ZD we're
getting our ears parsed we are yes I
mean my lip wax it has been a minute it
doesn't mean I'm starting to look like a
man no you don't someone called me sir
yesterday that's a lie it is a lie Liz
Lemon
it is a lie I was watchin 30 rock all
night last night except after season
four like it starts to get a little not
the same it's just the the reputation of
the show was weird because for year
after year before I knew what it was
they swept to the Emmys and they were
always winning and it was like annoying
I'm like Alec Baldwin Tina Fey was like
the Tina Fey yeah ever and then people
just once
decided to stop watching and their last
season was like they didn't even finish
it it was like half a season and I think
they went out as a joke and the last
season it's like not good interesting
how many seasons are there seven okay
I'll let you know what I think um yeah
it's just great joy it brings me you saw
stars born I did let's finally talk
about it because I've been saving up all
my all of my thoughts and what's
interesting after the first time I saw
it I had different thoughts after the
second time I saw it so the first time I
saw what I was going to say that you
wouldn't let me say is that I had never
heard of a star is born or seen any of
the previous films and I'd only seen
like the short commercials for it I had
no clue what I was going to see today no
clue that it was a love story that it
was spoiler alert a tragedy all I knew I
didn't know that the two of them were
like falling in love when they first
kissed I was like what are you guys
doing like you're supposed to help her
career like now you're gonna sleep your
way to the top of course that wasn't the
case and when I saw at the second time I
I did see the love there I wasn't
looking for it the first time um I just
really felt like one what is the message
of this movie what am i walking away
with like what was this story need to be
told over and over again it's not a
story that needed to be told four times
like maybe once okay young star you know
on the rise big star on the decline they
meet in the middle and she kills him but
four times I don't know about that and
they just don't know what the message is
like I guess the message would be one
star has to die in order for another to
be born the two people in a relationship
can't be equally successful and happy
right it has to be a balance of either
someone's miserable or someone isn't
famous yeah and like someone is like the
prize and someone's the pit okay here my
I have two big thoughts that I'll dive
into but just blanket statements are
this I went into it like wanting to love
it like I wanted to cry I like everyone
in the world it's like a stars board
stars born I've been like for six months
literally trying to get a screener cuz
I've been so excited to see it like I
really was just like so thrilled and
yeah yeah that's all I have to say
Bradley Cooper was a star a star he and
it's Chris Kyle voice on where he does
this like southern you know
DRO yeah and I loved everything he did
he really was playing two different
characters because when he was sober he
was so different than when he wasn't
when he was a drunk like he was
excellent and he deserves all the praise
and all the awards the music was
phenomenal Ivan Nam I just
I'm already bad watch me and then that's
don't you put it on the piano I'll
always remember this is why I got which
played a musical monday SoulCycle last
night oh my god I was great I think
people were crying and I've been time
Lady Gaga opened her mouth to sing like
I really firmly believe she is one of
the talents of our generation when it
comes to singing she's I'm so proud to
have her representing our generation I
feel like we makes older people like
respect and I respect the work that the
younger people are doing right and I
thought it was very interesting how like
the characters career trajectory was
really similar to Lady Gaga's how like
she always says and she says in five
four two like when she first got into
the business just like men like making
decisions for her and like the music she
was putting out wasn't necessarily like
what she wanted to be putting out but
she was just doing it to get a place and
now she's at a level where she can
release a jo-ann and like it's so who
she is and that was totally happening to
Hallie
like the music that didn't make it to
Joann that was a little too theatrical
for Joann so at the end of the day we
got a new lady Gaga album which is a
gift in and of itself but but but and I
pains me to say this but I'm a true
critic I'm not gonna okay I'm not gonna
just be biased I have a big problem and
my problem is that there's nothing
believable about Lady Gaga as an actress
like every time she spoke I was like
you're not Alli from Palm Springs Alli
from the valley your [ __ ] uh
Stephanie from New York like I just
wasn't believing anything she was saying
when she was acting especially in the
beginning like the first couple scenes
like I was just not but then when she's
saying Livia and Rose like she was just
going back and forth between two
extremes between like wow she's the most
talented singer of our generation and
wow she's a horrible actress I didn't
think she was a horrible actress and I
did find it believable because honestly
Lady Gaga's like Hannah Montana like
without the wig and the makeup like
she's so many different people like
honestly at one point in our lives like
even when she was the biggest star like
if she were walking down the street like
SIA like you wouldn't know who she was
so like without makeup and with the brow
hair and like the bad extensions like
the hair was terrible I with hair was a
whole plot within itself with the red
and choppy Brown it was terrible I so I
what I wasn't the acting didn't totally
bother me I just like I really enjoyed
it and I enjoyed it way more the second
time because I knew more of the songs
and I knew where the story was going so
I could anticipate in like then see
things that I had missed before and then
towards the end like I actually was sad
as opposed to just like what just
happened I didn't see that coming at all
oh I totally saw it coming I only
stopped coming when he went to rehab and
he told the shrink about yells yeah and
then I started seeing the scar on his
face and every time I started remind me
and I was like oh my god like we're not
out of the woods
no he's just like so hot and like I know
he was being terrible to her like when
he was drunk calling her ugly but like I
got his delivery was bad for sure but
like she was wrong like he was just like
trying to preserve her talent and she
was just like thirst monster with her
terrible manager who just wanted to
exploit her and make songs about why are
you looking at my ass and like total he
should never have called her ugly but
also like this whole plot of her like
being ugly like please like if they
wanted they could have gotten someone a
whole lot uglier like that was so stupid
Lady Gaga's not ugly like that was just
I wasn't believing traditionally
beautiful know for sure but like she's
not like what you think of when you
think of like a list celebrity star I
just wasn't buying any of it I I bought
most of it and I enjoyed it and I just
want oh I'm sorry
one more thing that I appreciate it so I
watched the old Judy Garland once so
each time they make it it's like 30
years later 30 years later and they
really do update to the time so like in
the Judy Garland when she was like a
actress singer which they all were like
singing in the rain style and like she
goes to awesome yes she was she was
doing weights lifted the Barbra
Streisand one like was just annoying as
hell I only saw five minutes yes but
like couldn't even get past it was he a
country singer Yeah right he was country
western I was thinking of him as like
Kings of Leon yeah Mumford inside Bruce
Bruce Springsteen you know he's like a
band version so it is country but like
maybe even the Chris Stapleton in 20
years Chris Stapleton great so and when
I saw what I really liked what they did
was I really liked how they up to
to the time sake it felt really
authentic like she goes viral on YouTube
right and the jammies they use SNL to
show that like she's really made it and
like that's a big deal to palette
Baldwin Alec Baldwin sat down but he
crushed it I think I'll go and talk I
like him better not with gray hair most
are silver foxes and he's got a nice
head of hair
oh but like when he like there's one
season like between season 2 and 3 on 30
rock like he gets a la Cryer and I'm not
here for it okay I'll look out for it
yeah look out for it well and also I
like you know oh so cool is like they
really were performing like at Coachella
last Mary and like they would get five
minutes of said time at other people's
concerts and I'm just so upset that we
missed it they used her their cello we
were there where were we they don't know
okay he sat on some [ __ ] people TV
interview I don't know there's really
like so much press I know and I think
they're in love
I thought or they want us to think
they're in love also the whole time I
was thinking like did they [ __ ] or did
they not [ __ ] and I've come to the
decision that they did not [ __ ] off
camera like while filming well you don't
actually [ __ ] in a film so the camera
real life obviously I don't think they
filmed porn I don't think I don't think
dad sex I hadn't thought about it much I
know they definitely want us to think
they're in love much like Zac Efron and
zendaya when promoting the greatest
showman and I think if it's a girl fun
wasn't Lovings and it was not no because
where are they now
but where is he talking about her now
and he also with the same thing he also
did the same thing with the Baywatch
co-star with the big titties oh and the
blue eyes Kelly is that her name no it's
Alexandra I was him Jack loves her
apparently she showed her tits in like
true detective and oh and then the world
was shut the titty of it all Lady Gaga's
breasts which I've seen because they
were in five four - surely five four -
yeah just like us
total Judy Garland was four eleven
according to Wikipedia which sounds
wrong and what did I say before the
titty of it all oh and then the bush him
at all
she's Jonah brush okay it was that part
of the movie it was brief Bush it was
Barbara brosher guy you know it was like
Laura Bush Hager like it was a quick
Bush Jenna Bush Hager Jagger Laura Bush
Hager is married to George oh my god
wait and the most interesting part of
the movie was the trailers before so
many films I didn't know do you see them
again movie about Dick Cheney no okay
you see there
a movie about bohemian rhapsody' no ween
well that's interesting like Queen sure
she was still we were gaps I thought it
was a I thought was a skit at first
and they'd some guy beating Bush who
looked nothing like Bush like eating
wings and then I only realized that the
guy he was talking to was Dick Cheney
I'm like oh they're trying to make him
be Bush what's the name dish no Bush's
being played by Sam Rockwell yeah like I
wanted to support their family and then
once I realized he was Bush I was like
oh he's like a cute Bush I don't know it
was very odd and then there was another
movie that I have to say Kevin Hart in a
serious film with Nicole Kidman and
Bryan Cranston yes we have to see me and
he oh he helps them aid the old man yeah
we some old men he has like a disease oh
well but he's a billionaire it looks
amazing
it looks I only saw that in the previous
movie it was funny the things you see in
the previews for the first it's like the
same genre of the film you see look if
you're watching a horror movie or only
Missy liked horror like pretty see
that's Steve Carell the Marwin trailer
of the little dolls like he gets beat up
you didn't see it I sawed him both
screaming no I didn't and I was there
for all trailers and it looks just like
so weird but there's some really good
cast do you have a problem like going
through an entire movie without going to
the bathroom no but I do like I go right
before me too and if I do have to go
during the movie I I actually I think
I'm strong like bowels and bladder
because I can hold it in I just can't
get up during a movie like what if I
miss the most amazing thing you know I
know when I don't think I've ever been
at the movie theaters and not had to go
to the bathroom at least once usually
twice do you have a problem being in a
movie and not checking your phone not at
all not last night I was loving it like
I just couldn't be bothered the first
time I saw it I was just like in it like
I forgot about my whole life and I was
just like in a star is born I was at
Coachella which I was I'm still so upset
about it but they were they did
stagecoach too by the way but then we
were there too but yeah I know they did
stagecoach I think at like 6:00 in the
morning before with extras like it
wasn't a real say no what what they did
for late
they used part of Lady Gaga's set but
not while we were there for sure and
they said to the little monsters if you
come dressed country/western not like
Joanne and not using poker face you can
come to a free lady gaga well Joanne is
really good that way you know what why
because that was all I had where that to
an to a alley Jackson concert
some women wear that shoe Jackson main
concert yeah this girl I just like I'm
never I'm always every film Bradley
Cooper does I'm more impressed with him
completely agree so when he did American
sniper is really when I fell in love
with him cuz one like he got so
different looking and he was so hot as
Chris Kyle like big man buzz cuz I wear
his wife I'd be like get back to that
shape yeah man I am call me Tyler what's
her name uh yeah yeah
Tatia Tatia oh yeah and like I'm tire
this is ever and you are Chris like and
when he did that movie I appreciate him
so much cuz I love a patriotic movie and
like a movie about America and the
sacrifices of our veterans so like I was
like oh we're on the same page me and
Bradley he's a patriot as am i and I
loved it even though he got snapped and
like I laughed and I cried
right and we said any movie that can
really make you do both like a guttural
laugh and a horrific cry that is a more
Sienna Miller of it all like that film
was just extraordinary I know in his
film trajectory his career is so
interesting cuz for a while he was doing
like hangover like role models type of
movies like just being the funny friend
and then he really just made such good
choices know American hustle like
totally but it just has a lot to do with
the fact that he's like so hands-on
right that doesn't hurt but sometimes
that does hurt actually because you
can't be taken seriously in any other
way but it's like he does the same
movies as like Paul Rudd and Seth Rogen
but none of them were cast for American
hustle nobody it's just because I think
he's like a really good actor I think he
has good management and good judgment in
scripts no sure but I think 50% of it
maybe more is just due to the fact that
he's like he's not hot he's incredibly
handsome right and like women want to
watch him like all I want to do I didn't
I was grounded it was a movie for
everyone it was okay so then I fell in
love with him there then he did um was
after American hustle Oh silver linings
playbook which do you not like oh my god
I love you do yes it's a great movie and
you wonder why because he was better
than Jennifer Lawrence she was pissed me
off the whole time like I was and he was
better than her but it was just annoying
again
a story yeah a story that didn't need to
be told but once it was told I was like
oh that's an interesting funny story
because here's the thing unless it's a
true story which should be told because
the truth is honestly it's the best way
like we said it's more
it's crazier than the [ __ ] that you
could make up so if it's a made-up story
like a star is born like it needs to be
just so complex and dynamic and makes
you think like I'm thinking about the
fact that I'm not thinking you know yeah
I guess well I just want to go back to
one moment stay with of course Brooklyn
a story that did not need to move and I
will take that to my grave you should
see oh no I don't [ __ ] with Saoirse
Ronan at all and we need to make the
next host movie of the week and we
should do it for this week
Country Strong because the stars born
was very country strong vibes I thought
soon and it was another movie that was
snubbed yeah left and right yeah because
it wasn't a true story right also air
guy was story that did not need to be
told necessarily but still enjoy the one
thing that put me off in the film that
like didn't put me off it was just like
so unnecessarily sad was when like the
dog was chilling outside the garage well
Bradley Cooper like slowly hung himself
like you would never do that to Theo
ever like open the crate with a bone
yeah well he didn't make a mistake that
looked good but like that was like so
sadder than he looks at town inside the
garage just like Lady Gaga said he waits
outside the door like this and then
that's what he did oh my god it was
really sad that was really sad I don't
know I liked it for sure and I love
going to the movies in it and it was a
conversation starter now I can engage
with other folks and even I think
mastaba
album a lot of people together like it
brought kind of sponsors together
country film old-school people who saw
the original star is born so like I like
that about it very blue heart and they
also liked the random celebrity cameos
that's my favorite like to a point like
in oceans a is that the sensible Oakland
yeah like they paid every single person
in the entire world to be in the movie
and it was like what are you trying to
hide like it's overkill right but this
one with like a little dash of Alec
Baldwin a sprinkle of Dave Chapelle I
liked it I liked it as well and I'd
liked how they used like modern things
right and I really liked it but in a
believable way they movie had nothing to
say the story had nothing to say except
for one thing that winning a Grammy for
Best New Artist means you're probably
the worst new artist a la know that you
can't like be successful in the industry
like without stripping away the good
parts of you right and like your talent
and it's like that the industry thinks
that that's the only thing that will
consume but I just want to let you know
I personally like I'll always remember
us this way and look what I found better
than why you well up in those jeans also
everyone please [ __ ] the [ __ ] off for
saying spoiler alert we said spoiler
before and we've been talking about the
movie now it's 10 54 20 minutes if you
haven't heard
headphones up and you hear us talking
about the movie that is your fault take
the headphones off and we've been
waiting a week to talk about the movie
so yeah please I'm the last person in
the world to see it oh my god and then
literally everyone acid doing at the box
office I feel like it's crushing it well
if we're not the movie sitter that I was
in was over a hundred years old like was
literally the senior discount and there
was an old man I mean Ben were standing
like up the stairs there was old man
like trying to get down the stairs and
it was like so sad and Ben like jumped
up and like helped the old man and I was
like you've never done that before I
like it was and I didn't even like
self-involved like in my own family
didn't even think like get up and hold
it help an old man find the hand railing
you know well like there's I don't know
if you could actually physically help me
because they were small and weak right
you're actually wouldn't be the best
candidate no not at all Ben what was so
that's good
yeah I'm he's representing the family
right now I'm respectful of by
association totally and having said that
without further - here are the Fast Five
story is that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast some breaking news this
morning Pippa Middleton welcomes her
first child with husband James Matthews
making Kate Kate Middleton and Anthony
Jess it's always nice when we can
welcome another and snitch s into the
group especially when that is a quarter
Jewish you know and royal right and this
brings me back to our conversation
yesterday cuz we were talking about how
like you and Ginny gets the
responsibility and not the thing
pitbull lives the dream she is of all of
the perks no she's a commoner but very
high class commoner
she has ties to royalty she married a
very rich also commoner but paparazzi's
obsessed with her they want to know
where she is at all times and she it's
pretty news yesterday when she enters
the maternity ward totally did you ever
um Keira Knightley said about yes I
didn't think I was very nice I didn't
think that was nice either she was
saying that like uh postpartum like Kate
Middleton leaving the hospital like
wearing makeup I just said a bad example
or just was a bad look like for women
because most women don't look like that
when they leave but after they give
birth which makes sense but like no
that's why she's royal and we're not no
also but like if I was you know like a
billionaire princess where the taxpayer
dollars at my disposal and I knew there
were cameras waiting for me after I
leave the maternity where like you bet
your ass I'm having a glam squad in
wardrobe right and that's more of like
the paparazzi spots and the people's
calls right for gym and showers out
there
like she's just responding to her
condition she didn't set those
conditions for herself yeah no I thought
that was mean and like she clearly has
like some other like bones to pick maybe
she like dated William you know what my
favorite thing is it's like when
celebrities in Hollywood like our
advocates for like feminism but then in
doing so tear other women down right
it's a you do realize that's the exact
opposite of what you you just want
equality for everyone except women who
leave the maternity ward wearing makeup
like do I like would I ever do that
no do I have a problem with Kate
Middleton doing it no because I like the
pictures if you want to like talk [ __ ]
talk [ __ ] about society that that's what
we require yeah and honestly the man
talk [ __ ] then I owe and nothing but if
he spends my change then he had it
coming okay sure he goes Pippa Middleton
welcomed her first child with husband
James Matthews the couple welcomed a
baby boy weighing 8 pounds 9 ounces on
Monday big baby
people confirms everyone is delighted
and mother and baby are doing well her
representative tells people like she has
a representative know that you think at
a pocket of royal probably her yeah I
think so too because they could use the
royal representative if they wanted to
right and I think how do we know that's
not her how do we know who that could be
to tell us rap because they would have
said Kensington Palace I think the
newest addition to the family makes her
older sister Kate Middleton and Anne
sneetches for the first time the royal
mom of three likely has plenty of sage
advice and newborn clothes to pass on to
your younger sister who was one of
Prince Louise very first visitors after
his birth in April so fund their kids
are growing up at the same time they
really are the Kardashians but we have
to UM we have to hear what our charity
has to say cuz I can't I can't hear any
news royal related until it carried you
know he speaks on it and whatever Gary
says I say really because he was not
nice to Eugenie you Jimmy oh he was it
yeah what he said everything was like I
thought she was the maid that's funny
it's funny but okay but here's the thing
but like I thought that her dress was
truly beautiful like I wouldn't change a
thing about it and like Megan's like he
went in on because it was not good as
well and the more I see other royal
wedding dresses like the more the more I
see pictures of Megan's dress like I
really think that like editors are face
tuning out the wrinkles like yeah you
know it was just like so such a Miss and
so I really felt like he stepped up to
the plate and being the only one
say that education to us of course no of
course yes and I got like flack for it
like but it's like when something's good
like say that it's good no I agree and
eugenie hit it out of the park out of
the park but no every time now someone
gets married they could maybe do a
side-by-side of Meghan's dress and even
when she put on that halter dress which
was much better it still it was no you
Ginny little waist thing you know it
wasn't like a timeless is it's just like
finally you look good like you're young
a skinny woman yeah but it was a halter
white sheath dress like right I mean and
it didn't really fit and also it was
like kind of like the car vibes that
were that made the photo I know it was
the Harry of it all you know it was the
palace the Jaguar and the Prince that
really made the dress stand out know if
she was standing like against a white
wall right I don't know that I'd be
singing its praises but whenever I don't
want to praise people having to tear
down Mac we don't have to praise you
just room but inevitably you compare all
the dresses because that's the only
frame of reference anyway and they
always compare it back to Kate's also
which was just the best at about
anyone's yeah but it had to be it had to
I mean she's gonna be the Queen right I
think yes eventually but like these
people never die totally not that I'm
like the best medical in the world and
like I just feel like English people
like they have different problems like
teeth they don't have like
illnesses you know well they probably
have a illnesses too but they do have
different problems right I know I mean
Royals have different problems right leg
out like Thomas Markel do you have gout
no but one time I was like doing acting
like a few years ago I was doing Atkins
for the first time in a while and I was
just eating so many fatty foods and I
was like I'm going to get gout like I'm
doing it wrong but gout isn't from fatty
foods it's from like expensive food no
it's from rickets or like caviar lobster
but you don't eat it's the King's
disease yeah but I was eating like eggs
with butter and cheese like very fatty
foods I know somebody who's got you do
yeah do they feel it in their toe yes
everyone knows who it is but like I
don't know if I should say doesn't mean
to say someone else go I think so okay
I'll tell you later
um it's a segue into our next story
which I'm going to switch it up because
I'm out the King's disease is often
associated with lottery winners if
you've ever watched real pains it is
when you win the lottery and you can
start like eating all these like buying
new things
yes and you change your home you eat all
these things that you're not used to and
might happen to someone because Mega
Millions and Powerball lottery jackpots
are near 1 billion dollars combined
right now oh my god we have to go
I love these stories me too because it's
like the whole world gets together and
like roots for everyone yeah and it's
like something we're all coming together
on and it's just like you know it's just
not contentious right you know it's
disappointing it's that like they
everyone buys a ticket and the day of
the drawing like they tell you where
that if there was a winning ticket and
where it was sent so like me in New York
with my 30 tickets before they even
announce a number I know it's someone
from Missouri you know and I read on to
check your tickets but it's like what
did I buy all the tickets for you I
can't wait for the numbers you know I
guess you could wait for the numbers
trips that episode oh my god friends of
course not where they all get the
lottery tickets and they decide what
they're gonna do and Ross like won't do
it look they all put 50 bucks in and buy
like a million tickets and then they're
gonna split it and Ross is like the odds
of you guys doing it are so slim like
I'm not doing this and then it's like
well wouldn't we win no it's great
upside I want a Netflix documentary on a
lottery winner like next whoever wins
this one next look should show up at
their door be like we're filming a
documentary I guess what do you
incentivize them with because they don't
need money and like see how their life
changes well there's a show it's a or no
it's some it's like TLC it's something
like the life of uh Oh MSNBC what sitcom
I don't know what it's called but it's
like they follow the stories of like a
couple lottery winners and like how they
spend their money when they get it and
then that kinda end up literally poorer
than they were before but like what kind
of lottery is like I want someone who
earned one billion dollars because I
don't think the end up poor them before
but sometimes if you win a couple
million dollars and you can comes to a
lifestyle you can end up [ __ ] than you
were also HGTV does a show called my
lottery dream home and with people who
win like local lotteries so it's never
more than like a million or to Ryan and
it's really interesting to see how much
of the million because you have to think
about it even so they don't live in New
York they live in like randoms like
Seattle so the most I've ever seen is
someone get like two to three million
and they all they still spend like half
a mil on their house which after taxes
and like after you buy the house doesn't
leave you with much no but like now you
have a nicer house and be living your
same life you have to keep up that house
Mo Money mo problems totally if someone
wins big in this week's lottery they'll
not only be set up her life they may
also set a record or come close for
earnings on a single Powerball or Mega
Millions ticket
Mega Millions jackpot is now six hundred
and fifty four million dollars making it
the second biggest Mega Millions jackpot
ever we need to go get the cash option
on this Mega Millions drawing is three
hundred and seventy two point six
million dollars since no one claimed the
Mega Ball during Friday's drawing one
lucky winner Ashley eigen of
Elizabethtown Kentucky took in 1 million
dollars during Friday's drawing for
matching the fireball numbers drawn
according to NBC that's nothing so it's
not the power the Powerball also the
Powerball
this week's Powerball has an almost
equally impressive top prize the game's
fourth largest jackpot in history now at
three hundred and forty five million
Mega Millions and we have to get
Powerball right or should we just get
like double of one no no I got a got a
spread out but this is so great and we
have to do it and how would you spend oh
my god this also reminds me of the
greatest episode of Blue Bloods when
they're in the car it's the most most
recent season finale so spoiler if you
don't watch season a Jackie it's just
you guys it's just partners Genco and
eddie and they're like totally in love
but they can't and they won't it's been
like eight years I'm just like we know
you're in love have sex and something
happens where they're in the car and
they're talking about they they're
having a conversation like we'd like
what would you do if you had five
million dollars like I would just split
it up and then all of a sudden like
someone gets shot and they're running
and they think Jimmy dies and sell this
and then it's all over and they're all
like freaked out because like her
partner almost just died and she's in
love with him so they like hug and they
like can't believe that they're not dead
and he whispers in her ear and he goes
it's been the five million on you what
would you on she didn't answer it's just
like beautiful you know and them oh man
so what would you spend your 300 million
on whoo 300 million okay I think I would
start I mean obviously Gucci bag Hermes
croc just wish she could you baggage you
baggage you back in 12 minutes yeah I
would start with like just going a
shopping spree of course maybe literally
spend a million dollars shopping just
for fun cuz I can and then I would buy a
second home in the country that would
say shame I need for Cleveland right now
so that I could stay in the city for
what country like upstate New York yes
somewhere probably like an hour and a
half out of the city so that like
whatever radius that is so that would be
maybe upstate New York maybe Poconos
Connecticut Connecticut Long Island okay
any like I an hour and a half I think
it's like the permit you're gonna spend
those sort of drive um couple mil yeah
like I wanted to be nice I want to like
look forward to going there and then I
will get a car
or to take me there yeah because now I
don't have to worry about getting my
license Oh huh um then I will looked
inward in the city and probably move
subhan dose - no I don't like pent
houses I have vertigo so I can't be that
high up so I would want like something
low but but spacious yeah um I think I
would buy if I felt it was a good
investment but if it wasn't nice to just
always a good man I could just keep
renting if I had three men say that and
then it's like it's a good investment
yeah for a hundred years but like for
ten years or however long you plan on
being there like yeah it's still a good
investment I don't know like you know it
is I don't know
not all real estate okay if I had three
hundred million dollars I would put two
hundred million of it in a checking
account that like it just earns interest
like my money's making money so I don't
really have to work like and come here
every day no offense and then with my
hundred eighty tous anymore if you want
a lottery no I would I would in my new
penthouse I would make the studio and
have hair and makeup so that I could let
her wake up at ten o'clock and they
could lend me up and ten thirty I'd be
in the chair totally so 200 mil gone in
savings the 100 mil I would just improve
my life in every way like I would buy a
house in LA and a private jet
oh yeah and I would buy a bigger house
in New York and like a Hamptons country
house as well
Car and Driver for sure full time glam
squad security um I think I would stay
in my current apartment building but
just take like the nicest one okay you
know what I mean like I live on like the
lower floor with my the other renters
and then I would go like up with like
the owners you know I would definitely
have Changizi on retainer I would have
all my doctors on retainer like living
in my house because I feel like I'm too
lazy to go to the doctor and get a chef
and I would get like a full maids
housekeeping like I would get a butler
okay that's what I would get with a
little button on my phone then I'm like
ding so I don't to get up and get the
tiger if I can't reach a clicker I'm
like oh hello Marcel yeah chives his
name would have to be chives totally I
think I like all the time and then what
we do have for Theo I mean a palace of
his own yeah brothers and sisters and
they're like a full-time caretaker who
looks just like me so that he doesn't
forget me and smells like you yeah oh my
god Theo got his bath yesterday and he
smells like heaven
like there's Theo's oh I know she takes
being like extra cute recently and I
just wonder what he's trying to prove
okay so Theo's groomer comes to the
house her name is Ali and she gets the
most premium content especially in our
new kitchen that's like has a handheld
sink thing like it's really much better
for her and he was being such a good boy
yesterday I got his Instagram up with no
job I think I'm gonna see him later oh
yeah come on by cos grossly under
followed like he's the most beautiful
dog in the world and especially on
Instagram and he post premium content he
has a great personality and like I
thought like a measly 60 if I don't know
why he doesn't have millions of phone me
too
and the dogs that like do no offense are
ugly it's like the uglier and more
freakish your dog looks like more
instruments not missing a limb not
interested not to me I mean but that dog
tuna look like that
it's disgusting I don't follow any dogs
I mean I don't say except for of course
my nephew Cetus but also today is my
last day as a woman with no couch as a
girl with no couch well you have a couch
but no I said girl with no new couch I'm
so excited for you can't wait to come to
Tuesday Wednesday Tuesday oh it's coming
on Wednesday that's tomorrow
are you ready for the next story I would
also buy a villa like in Turks and
Caicos but I kind of like would want to
hop around for a little bit before I
want to go to a lot of different
vacation spots to know which one's my
favorite okay we've only really like
been to a few so what if there's
something better out there and I'm sure
there's like a private island for like
you might want to be there for the
privacy so I'm gonna go buy those
Powerball and Mega Ball tickets but do
you know that like it's really hard to
buy a lottery ticket it's like I can't
find them anywhere so you think you're
going to like a new Stan Bodi again they
would have it but they don't really yeah
and also where does the billion dollars
come from people pay when you like you
buy tickets all that money adds up most
people lose and it goes towards the pot
but how does the company make money
because they're not putting it all
towards the pot that's how much Pete
like like the fact that the government
takes tax on a lottery it's like one of
the most [ __ ] up things so rude it's
like [ __ ] off can't anyone win anything
without your grimy little hands in mine
okay they literally have their hands in
everything
[ __ ] off it makes me so mad it's like
where are they when you need them no not
ever
we're okay
next story ariana grande returns Pete
Davidson engagement ring after split
diamonds aren't always a girl's best
friend Ariana Grande has returned her
$93,000 pear-shaped engagement ring to
now ex fiance Pete Davidson TMZ reported
as for their other joint assets
such as their pet pig named piggy smalls
it appears the 25 year old singer will
keep the porker Davidson won't ever be
too far away from his former pet as he
recently revealed that he had piggy
smells tattooed on his torso presumably
grande is also remaining in the 16
million dollar apartment she purchased
for her in Davidson piggy smells was
just one of the many tattoos Davidson
kapa Grande though page six recently
revealed that he had his dangerous woman
inspired tattoo covered up just days
before the split news broke that was
weird why didn't we why did that raise
any red flags
I don't know because now he has a big
heart which is [ __ ] weird and lame
for like a boy and takeo as hell yeah
and those ears are the cutest things
ever I know and even if he slit with her
he should have kept them because it's
cool it's like playboy he has like so
many tattoos really related to their
relationship that like what do you do I
don't know like that's why you have to
just make a good relationship but Ariana
has his dad's like FDNY shield on her
foot like but that's also cool cuz she's
just honoring a victim of 9/11 right but
like for her it's tied to like this to
multiple relationships and like what is
she gonna do with it
she can't cover that up no I don't think
that's as bad as like it's not as bad no
it's not like that it'd be like her
having SNL tattooed yeah no no it's not
as bad but honestly could she I mean she
had to give the ring back for so many
reasons even though in New York it's
considered a gift if you break up like
you don't have to give it back by law
but like it was the right thing for her
to do cuz like you know he needs a 93
grand so like buy more drugs for himself
and his friends I'm like she doesn't
really need it I'm like maybe rent an
apartment right like he's homeless now
he really needs it and she doesn't she
could just buy herself another one like
if she's really missing the bling you
know who I've been thinking about a lot
Franky Grande so he put up a video on
his Instagram like talking to his sister
like call her it was so weird and he was
a con you know you gotta keep on keep on
breathin and it was like the thirstiest
video every Thursday this morning when I
was thinking about like what am I gonna
say on the shows today I was like I
haven't talked about freaking grande
because for as much as we talk about
their sponsor Jenner I was like we've
never spoken about Frankie grande and
I'm Rebecca and forth because I really
feel like he's a good brother and he
like owns the fact like his sister's a
brother
right and you know that like he all he
wants to do is be the center of
attention and like he'll never ever ever
be and he does really good work for like
the LGBTQ community so like I'm
reluctant to say anything but like
sometimes I just see things and I'm like
you have to be stopped no I don't see
enough about
him for him to bother me but when I do
I'm just like wow you're super thirsty
but you know it's gotten you pretty far
and like now you're Ariana's brother and
you're famous for being her brother and
like you just want to be famous so like
maybe everyone really is happy and then
like you're in the celebrity world to
now sort of so you can like be there for
her and it's good for her it's good for
him so I'm like happy for them I just
like don't really want to like be into
my comic but it's like when he's like
with her at award shows like just being
extras hell it's like okay like Taylor
Swift couldn't show up I didn't what do
you have Frankie grande Thanks well then
also have a significant or is the
biggest star in the world like literally
in the world and the best you're gonna
do is like Celebrity Big Brother Dancing
with the Stars like I don't feel like
for a thirsty as he is and how famous
his sister is and how much access he
probably gets from her like he could be
doing so much better but like what and
what talents does he was gonna say what
does he want to do like because they
could come out with a song together no I
don't think he sings because when he's
saying keep on breathing in that weird
video it was not good so he just wants
to be a thirsty Instagram influencer and
he is and have you ever done a soul
cycle class with him
apparently he's like always in SoulCycle
classes like in the front being so extra
annoying oh then we would get along yeah
I just don't know why I've been thinking
about him a lot recently I actually
didn't think about him at all because
I'm not only because I saw this video it
like triggered memories like I'm just I
don't know where I stand on the Frankie
grande of it all I stand I'm like that
I'm happy for you guys just leave me out
of it right you know he doesn't do you
like more hosting stuff right I feel
like maybe he just hasn't maybe he's not
good at it right like me it's really
hard it's hard to read off of a
teleprompter and just like speak know
like he goes like the red carpet at the
VMAs cuz MTV will really let anyone do
that these days yes they will um but
maybe he's like can't even hack it you
know oh my god sorry he wasn't even on
Celebrity Big Brother he was on a
regular big you're lying I swear oh my
god you're right he was with ramsey yes
and actually Huzur auntie taking the
news I don't know I haven't spoken to
ANSI they were like best friends I'm
yeah brother
well also with Frankie Grande my bad
today crazy that he wasn't even on
Celebrity alright so some people they
didn't know who he was in the house and
then like one girl but kind of figured
it out I don't know I don't watch but
like it was really weird that nobody
knew who he was
and also there was like a death in his
family while he was in the house but
like you're not allowed to but they tell
you do they
yes and so I think he liked ya there
grandpa died yeah sad
did he leave I think maybe or
non-celebrity where he was able to make
some phone calls right it's like that's
how thirsty you are he's not doing it
for the money because he could their
family is they come for money and
Ariana's a quadruple billionaire like
she doesn't need it so that's up thirsty
are you won't come off your stupid
reality show when there's a death in
your family he's only kidding you win a
million dollars when you were in the
house like that million dollars would
have done nothing for him like I need it
like that's out there you won't even
leave Wow well let's make sure he didn't
leave maybe no I know he didn't well
even if he left he he came back I think
but like I would leave for good I wonder
if you're able to you never know what
those maybe weather's like this scary
issue in terms of signing your life away
they asked us to like come an audition
and it was just no that was also the
Amazing Race oh right
definitely not that hasn't been
hilarious no I would entertain the idea
of Celebrity Big Brother cuz they have
queen-size beds
what about celebrity Amazing Race no
exist yet no like first of all
travelling is my worst nightmare
traveling on camera is something I can't
even get lucky and it's like you fit
completed challenging you run to the
airport right you don't have bags packed
flight sober there's no doubt the Sky
Club yeah oh my god so true Wow
never those are the real heroes okay
next up the little tech news Apple fixes
beige bagel emoji apple has released a
new version of its forthcoming bagel
emoji now including cream cheese this
aims to address concerns raised about
the previous design Wow like the world
is so stupid
when Apple first released the new emoji
support in iOS 12.1 beta 2 many were
quick to criticize the bagel what
Midwestern bagel factory did this bagel
come out of asked nikita Richardson of
grub Street today Apple released beta 4
of iOS 12.1 and the bagel design has
changed before it was a bagel and open
bagel with nothing on it and now it's an
open bagel with cream cheese one
challenge for the bagel emoji may have
been taught may have been that it's
tough to make any big oh look appetizing
without some kind of filling while this
update may not please those who prefer
bagels with different contents it does
seem closer to what people want to
consume
I mean likes Mitch
we'll never use this because she hates
cream cheese cream cheese but like but
like what's wrong with this first baby I
don't think the original bagel was so
bad and now that they had a cream cheese
like it definitely looks better don't
get me wrong but like the emojis are so
[ __ ] tiny like it's literally at
11:11 make-a-wish cuz you back at your
bag Gucci bag Gucci bag Gucci bag that
you're back with your back Gucci bag
it's hard to say Mega Millions lost a
million times fast Mega Millions Mega
Millions Mega Millions Mega Millions
Mega Millions not the best I are amazed
crock-pot him Seth ermes crock Hermes
croc Hermes croc Hermes croc [ __ ] it
remains grower maybe this cross say
garage ten times fast crash crash crash
cries cries cries cries cries are so
small this is such a minut detail like
who [ __ ] cares no and it's like yes
without anything on it it doesn't look
super appetizing but you're not eating
it and like if they wanted to make it
look more like a because I do admit the
original it's just like a plain become a
PC yeah like a necessity see it egg
bagel something like not [ __ ] plane
looks like a joke could be a glazed
doughnut cut in half because now you're
alienating the snitch
cuz it's doesn't the people who are
gluten free discriminating lactose
intolerant cream cheese like it's kind
of a polarizing thing like it's a little
gross no in the fact that people put
cream cheese and desserts like it's
disgusting like I think that cheesecake
is one of the most disgusting things in
the entire universe and if you have
eaten cheesecake in the last 30 days do
not even speak to me no I like
cheesecake I haven't eaten last 30 days
so I can continue to sit here but I just
like now that I think about cream cheese
it's like you never lick the knife yeah
it's like high cheese it's like you eat
it with your eyes closed do you except I
didn't eating cause she's once a day now
and I'm loving it people who like to eat
packets of butter oh my god literally
sends a chill down my spine
who does that a lot of people Wow well
bagel with butter would look weird no it
should been a poppy seed bagel I don't
know who cares totally there's so many
other emoji issues like where are the
redheads
I need thank you sister I'm a
spokesperson
oh but like who cares
we have way bigger issues in this world
like that is just so crazy and what's
craziest is that Apple even listen to
you guys right like honestly I love when
people are upset about something and
then like nobody answers them do you
know any it looks like because people
are in this day and age they're like
always upset about something taking to
Twitter like get their pitchforks 10
proof yeah they've got the reasons and
so like what an apple like gives in like
oh keep complaining will and will
indulge you like no you're setting a bad
example like if anyone ever complains
like Liberty someone complained about
the commercial we did yesterday like
literally grab a spoon and eat my
[ __ ] ass because like I couldn't care
less about what you have to say like
this is my job like you don't I mean so
I know so so many toasters love it so
much and anyway the comments were so
cute I was like smilin Shecky it was the
greatest comer I watched it again and I
showed bad because like I was so proud
and I never watch our show because my
voice like makes me want to die
but first of all it was hilarious it was
organic and it whenever the toasters do
post about like other people's podcasts
or like it's so annoying it's too many
ants it's like so obvious it's not even
funny to just like read off a piece of
paper so like we did the opposite of
that like we were funny engaging
relatable and it really was a true story
I did you feel like I'm getting you Chad
but and it also mentioned this wonderful
product that I didn't even know about
and now I do and so I'm sure that mr. so
like the fact that like someone wanted
to DME and like literally give me a
critique like first of all don't [ __ ]
DME
second of all you're wrong three I'm not
even gonna listen to you cuz you're done
sorry I like welcome in a mood today
with my migraine
I understand sister well we only have
one more story a man was tasered by
police after refusing to stop having sex
with a car exhaust oh my god breaking
news stagecoach line up Saturday Sam
hunt and Luke Combs wait I need to see
it I need to see the waiting structure
we're buying tickets now and we did send
it was that one was she just she's say
to assign up oh but she didn't say oh my
god I'm on the Twitter welcome to
stagecoach okay ready
oh god oh god okay Friday Luke Bryan
Cole Swindell Kayne Brown Bret Michaels
Scotty McCreery rusty dick rusty dick
Devon Dawson on a headliner Friday Luke
Bryan okay who's a headliner Saturday
Sam hunt who's ahead and Luke combs cam
lynyrd skynyrd Lanco Michael ray Sammy
Kershaw Jesse James Decker cuteness
behind the any respect in the country
community and then Sunday Jason Aldean
Old Dominion Law
Elena Tom Jones Danielle Bradbery
okay I have to say something I'm
disappointed who do you wish was there
where's he's he Musgrave she headline
last year here's Mary Morris she
probably isn't putting out a new album
before that so what she would be doing
the same song she did two years ago I
feel like so many people are missing
from what I need to see it
where's Haskell Clyde's where's dan +
Shay where's Sanjay no it's just like
you know okay so they've the first two
people and then like the bots and like
the next two and the next two are
usually like huge stars like like Lynyrd
Skynyrd and cam being on the second line
second to last
no like it goes like big medium small
like the fact that it goes Sam hunt and
then cam like they might have a second
biggest of the day I love Sam hunt like
I actually when he has me music like I
am amongst his number one of fans I get
the Spotify presale code but like he has
one album how is he the headliner
totally um like a little disappointment
we're going it right and that's me the
less acts that we have to see like the
more we can relax and drink backstage
where the [ __ ] is damage I I don't know
that's hurtful
who else isn't there let me check my
Spotify playlists to see the
disappointment Wow
where's Bradley Cooper I'm really
disappointed like I bet we're going cuz
like where the [ __ ] is Kacey Musgraves
whatever I'm saying we're sorry too
George line where's Mason Ramsay where's
Florida Georgia line where's Kelsea
Ballerini
where's Carrie Underwood where's
everyone this one second everyone's
missing where's that Brown Band
where's raelynne where's Hunter Hayes
are you gonna be okay no I'm really
excited
where's Lady Antebellum when we're on
stage is Brett Eldredge where's Brett
yeah Wow
oh my god [ __ ] that hurts so bad did you
hit your funny bone here where's Blake
Shelton where's brothers Osborne this
sucks
Keith Urban I'm honestly the only person
who's right right he's everywhere the
only person AMAs the only person that's
there that I can actually the only
person that I care about his hair is
Luke combs and like rusty dick no no
will be more than I and Lauren Elena I'm
fine but it's like
everyone where the [ __ ] is everyone what
happened I'm so excited
me too I think we need to put in our
calendars to be don't and I've got to
work on getting some sort of press pass
like the one we had last time was good
whisper it was two years ago like I've
know that girl still works there
have you or you or anyone you know works
for stagecoach please hit me golden
voice golden voice yeah also we have to
figure out our housing situation we
should we wanted to do this with the
breath we did I see the thing again yeah
the housing suit Oh fer stagecoach did
you do a toast influencer house but for
stagecoach yeah
only the best influencers go to
stagecoach totally like who would beat
up Lauren B in Amanda in our house
obviously uh actually that has they say
that was mad cute we should ask them
like how do you get a house would you
make these plans like now yeah and who's
coming cuz like I need to split up the
cost
featuring Guy Fieri's stagecoach
smokehouse I just have to say I went to
a Guy Fieri restaurant in an airport in
Bogota and I ordered chicken fingers and
it was literally the most disgusting
thing ever it looked like fish and chips
it was so I didn't eat that mean they
were chicken fingers truly who are these
people also we have to get to the story
cuz I've a okay this is the fifth and
final story oh we're on track though
Ryan Malick 24 from Newtown in Kansas
pleaded guilty took quote food and less
vicious lascivious behavior in the car
park of an apartment building court
documents show that's what we get for
using like a British outlet yeah they
might be hastily smell behavior oh you
are from the such a pretentious
[ __ ] when police arrived at
scene they found Malik trying to put his
penis into the car exhaust have we said
penis on the show before now we have
penis penis penis penis penis could go
forever penis penis now we're just
annoying the podcast people but like I'm
not like the people who work in this
office I'm not embarrassed to let me
neither
despite the penis penis penis penis
penis penis penis penis penis penis
penis an easy one to say over yeah penis
penis penis penis penis you want to join
the pen15 glad I didn't get that joke
literary till three years ago despite
the police presence and oblivious mallet
continued in his efforts and ignore the
officers attempts to stop him an officer
had to taser him and he was handcuffed
and taken to the hospital for treatment
according to documents his actions were
seen by
witnesses it stated how Malek quote
unlawfully intentionally and publicly
exposed a sex organ or exposed a sex
organ in the presence of another person
who is not the spouse of the offender
and who is not consented thereto with
intent to arouse or gratify the sexual
desires of oneself or another okay so
basically he stuck his penis and I like
that little pipe that Kenneth Parcell
okay but here's the problem
it's disgusting but what's illegal about
it that it's that other people saw his
penis yeah you can't expose yourself
what masturbated in public yeah got it
and like imagine a little sex you have
to be have any like want to [ __ ] a car
and it's like is it was it his car and
otherwise your sodomizing no one else's
property yeah and I really feel like I
have the perfect girlfriend
oh who okay I'll give you a clue ready
uh Mary Katherine Gallagher yeah cuz I
she like to make out with trees he likes
to [ __ ] cars cute right like they did be
like a cute pairing cute little do out
except she doesn't exist and she's older
than him yeah well now she is but I
would say like in her crime right in
your heyday at least my mother didn't
Amy well after Bob hot water this is
such a great movie that I feel like
isn't appreciated enough by our
generation because we were watching it
we were too young to be watching it
right no but like the gigantic ho age it
was like they appreciate it wholehearted
I think it's like a clueless type thing
for people like Andy Cohen yes it's such
a good movie sometimes what's crazy
though is that it's based off an SNL
character what like they made yeah
that's actually that's not the first or
last time that that's happened what's
her name Molly uh Molly Shannon she is
it such a great career like she's in
everything she's had never been kissed
she's in
Ricky Bobby Talladega she makes out with
Robbie Bobby from accounting and she's
like making out with the pencil and the
comment she's so funny she's so funny
and she's like such an underrated
like she's like not that famous but
she's like a legend do you know any
Fisher I think she's rated like I feel
like she has the exact career that she
wants and like she gets a ton of respect
she has a tailored respect she sees a
movie that she wants to be in like
they'll put her she can request it yeah
yeah no she is so great like I think
she's like one of my favorite actresses
and when she didn't maybe I'm like oh
this is gonna be funny for sure she's
hilarious what else does she and she's
into everything what else is she in
she's like everything yeah I love her
and I love her friendship with Andy
Cohen she's like one of
like 20 people who like invitation if
someone cancels like we'll just fill in
they have Rachel Dratch like whenever
you know someone cancelled what my
childre is on mark and Kelly yes john
benjamin hickey yes john mayer sometimes
Jerry O'Connell - Jerry O'Connell Bruce
Bozzi is bartending when the bartender
oh really she's not that famous to be
like an actual chair who else
definitely Kelly Anderson yes there's
just like his crew not as JP but like if
he needed her she would come yeah that's
nice I feel like when they first became
friends like Andy needed friendship with
SJP and now like SUV needs friendship
and Andy like she is so like like five
years ago with Paltrow where she's like
so you know and now like she needs be
brought back down to earth she needs to
do okay and he needs to do for SGP what
I did for Greta Paltrow so why don't you
just go hang out with Sarah Jessica
Parker I'm not interested okay like if
she was like hey you want to come to my
store I'm like no I'm not going downtown
anything else you want to add oh I do i
added shows in Hoover Alabama Winnie
Bernard is day away November 30th and
which is Ana's bachelorette party says
she has to move it
November 30th I'll be in Hoover Alabama
and then sooner literally in three weeks
Charlotte North Carolina on November 7th
and I was like I didn't even realize
like so many friends in like Charlotte
like had to give me tickets and I just
forgot TP geez headquarters are in
Charlotte and I forgot to resume tickets
and I don't know if there's left so
go-to girl with no job I think there's
always tickets like that you can like
bring a folding chair so that's the
thing but now after my birthday what
time are you flying out this better not
to stir my birthday dinner no I'm gonna
fly out at I booked the flight yesterday
at like Newton okay
where we going yeah ah splendid oh yeah
that's a good one that's like my
favorite restaurant is it okay it's like
I just like I'm now realizing we have to
be fat at that restaurant you know I
just want delicious pasta and they cook
it like they cook it and then they bring
it out in like their little stove and
like cook it right outside for you so
that's all I want for my birthday I'm
really like is Ben Gonyo
he's delicious pasta yeah no you know
look I really feel like I hit a level of
maturity like two years ago when I just
like really stopped caring about my
birthday
you hit a level of maturity when you
stopped do it when you stop like
choosing a bar and inviting everyone on
Facebook to your birthday no actually I
disagree because like no
go ahead okay ready you get a level of
maturity when you stop like spending
money like making a private room like
just inviting everyone to a bar it's
like fun and then you finally have an
excuse let's see all these I feel like
you it's a level of maturity when you
get a private room you spend money
because you have money now cuz you're
mature whereas before like everyone you
picked like a bar on the Lower East Side
you're like everyone meet here and it's
like everyone from college and my
friends just won as many people there as
possible as strong as possible ya know
like my birthday this year literally was
thirty people but it was like an its own
space right that's mature yes I agree
that was my birthday last year own space
yeah what was last year would you do um
mr. Kenan oh yeah that was so classy
that was so 25 and now what are your I'm
not even doing I'm not gonna do anything
like that I just want dinner with my
family and delicious pasta I couldn't
agree more
well thank you all for listening make
sure to help my shows and chocolate and
everybody's work and if any of you have
one laying around just let me know and
then go to bed like I feel like I can
get but the crock I don't know it's very
unattainable um but thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube and Facebook but soon
it's just gonna be YouTube so you should
start migrating over there um we're also
available as a podcast as a as podcast
in iTunes and podcast or stitcher Public
Radio Spotify tonight you should
progress down rain I didn't should cover
you though yeah you're fine
um so make sure you're headed over there
subscribe leave a review so we can be in
the top five and beat Polonius Florida
what else that's it that's it we'll be
back tomorrow with another swell show
for you and Thursday we have been so
start getting the questions ready
you